tour avec nous il tourne avec nous
tuis il vont t revenir versour pour pas
qu'il Ste voil
voilà il nous
suiv
Mor voilà maintenant un peu il vont
venir vers nous voilà un tout petit peu
voilà voilà t arriver vers nous voilà
pas trop pas
trop en courant en
cour
à droite il du mouvement plus à droite
est vachement fond c'est super là voilà
à
droite les couleurs sont magnifies voilà
voilà ça bien bien ça voilà bien large
bien voilà c'est beau c'est voilà voilà
voilà ça c'est super
voilà c'est pas grave c'est bien c'est
bien c'est
bien voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
et il tourne avec N
super fait les tourner Fran fais les
tourner
voilà un peu plus à ta
gauche ah il
finabe soleil qui revient merci il Rev
attention il va revenir ouis revient
très
fort très serré voilà là
attention joli ça l'écran c'est
magnifique tu Mo qui soleil ombre ouais
mais c'est pas mal comme
ça
un peu plus loin à gauche qui VI en
courant vers nous qui un paquet qui
court
ils arrivent tous vers
nous c'est be
ça il March il arrê de
marcher c'est bien d'avoir 12 de face
comme
ça
ça c'est un plan génial pour expliquer
qu'en Afrique la moitié de la population
à moins de 20 ans tu vois
ouais ah ils se tiennent ils se tiennent
il sont marrant les
gosses ah il y en a même qui font des
des culbut CIS pas il
a tu souffles gaffe tu souffles beaucoup
même c'est bon c'est va
tu as de m'en faire une pas du tout au
contraire
gentil doucement doucement pas trop
c'est bon c'est bon là ça bouge plus là
ça y est comm se
fatiguer jemonter c'est pour ça c'est
bon pour nous ce qu'il fa là non c'est
bien un plan ou pas un large quand même
moi je prendrai pas l'école comm tu veux
je te laisse faire ok vas-y vas-y vas-y
fais fais emmerde
pas est-ce que tu as envie
ouais tu as
raison non tu vois c'est c'est marrant
la voir comme de la matière quoi ouais
ouais ok enfin faisons faisons d'abord
un comme ça c'est l'école et puis après
on faut bien l'assurer c'est un
important pour nous
ça regardez qui arrivent comme des fous
bah tu vois ça par exemple to c'est pas
beau quoi ouais non
mais
doucement doucement
doucement ah tu toujours large là ouais
bah on ser c'est bon on a tu as ce qu'il
te faut c'est bon bah oui oui ok bon bon
c'est bon allez tu peux te sauver alors
on fait on fait la
Frip VO
de oui je vous écoute monsieur s' vous
plaît il y a les autorités à reporur qui
demandent si vous avez une une
autorisation pour la photographie
affirmatif monsieur je va vous la
montrer quand on va se poser et sinon
vous pouvez vous adresser à l'équipage
de l'avion il doiv avoir une copie
également
ok c'est bien reçu en fait c'est la
mairie qui a appelé pour demander et ils
m'ont répercuté l'information euh la
demande de la mairie c'est pourquoi je
vous je vous l'adresse il n a aucun
problème monsieur on a évidemment
l'autorisation et si vous avez le
contact avec l'équipage de l'avion ils
ont une copie et sinon moi je vous la
montre quand on se pose ok bien réussi
merci c'est moi qui vous remerci
monsieur on fait la
FR a eu un petit coup de au début de
l'EN rouler là ah bon je sa pas si pas
vu c'est bon c'est bon juste comme ça
quand même parce que allez on fait le fr
prix de problème le dommage très dommage
c'est qu'il y a une voiture j juste
devant ah elle était pas là tout à
l'heure mais non là elle est elle est là
alors on va y aller quand même tu
descends un peu ou la lumière là tu
descends c'est à droite à droite oui je
vois mais er est en train de faire un
plan je termine je termine
ou non non c'est bon là la bingle
dérange pas allez cut
alors